es el más reciente ataque ruso contra
kiev que no logró afectar la capital
ucraniana aunque los restos de cohetes
se pudieron ver en las calles la ciudad
fue atacada desde el aire por Rusia por
novena vez en este mes el ejército
ucraniano dijo que derribó 29 de los 30
misiles crucero que tenían como objetivo
varias regiones del país y que ninguno
había alcanzado con éxito la capital sin
embargo los residentes sufrieron las
consecuencias
me desperté y salté de la cama la gente
dice que sus ventanas están rotas las de
plástico aguantaron las de Maderas se
rompieron
la caída de escombros provocó dos
incendios en kiev uno en un garaje y el
otro en un edificio no Residencial
también se escucharon explosiones entre
regiones centrales mientras que las
autoridades dijeron que una persona
murió y dos resultaron heridas luego de
un ataque con misiles en odesa en el
suroeste a principios de semana las
defensas aéreas ucranianas interceptaron
un intenso ataque ruso en kiev en el que
se habrían disparado seis misiles y
Supersónicos kingshall Rusia asegura que
destruyó un sistema de defensa aérea
pero permaneció operativo según dos
funcionarios estadounidenses los
sistemas de defensa occidentales como el
han sido cruciales para proteger a kiev
de las múltiples ofensivas rusas los
ataques se producen cuando Ucrania se
prepara para lanzar una contraofensiva
para recuperar territorios que han sido
ocupados por Rusia